would you be cut dead in the little Nas
cat outfit did you see the little it's
like that it's squeezing him up the
bottom and it's squeezing them down in
the front and there's really I mean gay
is one thing not one hint of you being a
man left is another what's Wild is how
how they're using him to Market him you
know he gets all the eyeballs and God
forbid somebody else stands out there
and says hey boys be a man hey boys
stand up for yourself hey go out there
and defend yourself hey be protective of
women to take care of the folks around
you you know go out there and make some
money go out there and do something for
yourself if we give a message that is
very much of a pro-man message God
forbid you say something like that but
little Naz X hey put him all over the
place you know what he's wearing oh this
is this guy's a superstar he's a hero
and unfortunately it's confusing a lot
of different people but for me to wear
something like that I don't even think I
would wear something like that privately
for my wife no no and nor would she want
you to I think I speak on her behalf she
would not want me to I've seen Borat
it's not a good look no I will stay for
the record we've been watching in the
morning with my kids uh because I follow
him on insta videos of Jocko willink you
know who's like the Navy SEAL to end all
Navy Seals oh yeah and this morning we
watched a video uh it was it was uh
Jocko discussing with Leif Babin who
married my friend Jenna Lee from Fox
Business
um uh buds training and how the Seal
team is like so much about so much more
than buds trading yes it's difficult but
it's like you carried some logs and
water the way they described it like it
doesn't compare at all to combat and War
and like that is who I want especially
my boys listening to and looking at
somebody like a you know some a man of
service a man of Honor a man who in some
of his other messages says whatever it
is it's your fault you take
responsibility not somebody else you
that's this whole thing extreme
accountability
um not this not these ridiculous people
Pat I can't
well listen this is why uh Jaco is
another Super necessary voice and what
is happening is if you ask me what the
biggest leak is the challenge we're
having with parents and kids is whoever
you and I edify as the hero the kids
want to be whatever we edify the kids
want to be so if you edify a man like
Jocko and your son is watching and
saying hey son watch this man Jocko
that's what you call a man your son's
going to be like my mom is edifying
Jocko I want to be like Jocko when I
grow up I want to be like Rogan when I
grow up I want to be like this man when
I grow up right these guys are showing
there's a guy named Petro's good friend
is an entrepreneur he's doing things
where father and sons are coming
learning about how to become men there's
a bonding thing that's going on with the
father and son they're doing push-ups
they're training they're helping each
other right they're going out they're
doing all these exercises there's a lot
of good opportunities out there I read a
recently we did a video on why the
number one earners immigrants in America
are Indian Americans not native
Americans indian like from India
Americans they make more money on
average in America than any other
ethnicity in America including whites
they make on average 120 000 per year
number two just so you know is that
ninety five thousand dollars and whites
were at sixty five thousand dollars so
then you said this is kind of
interesting let's take a look at this
because there are only one percent of
the U.S population but eight percent of
all the startups you know when they're
going to technology and all this stuff
there's all these success stories of how
they invest their kids into stem all
these things that they're doing so then
I went on this one website to see what's
so special about Indian parenting that's
different than others so you go to this
website
it's called India parenting they have
these 10 points there and one of the
points was how they edify whatever
Behavior they want so you over edify you
edify and say see what Johnny did great
job Johnny see what that guy's doing
great job that's what you call it either
that's what you call this that's what
you call that versus American parents
are like where it's okay if they feel
that way well it's okay if you feel this
way well it's okay if you feel that way
no that's a leader that's a man that's
this they're edifying them right but one
of the points also out of the 10 of
Megan which was kind of interesting is
they also judge they're not afraid to
judge bad behavior and said they're very
judgmental of bad behavior interesting
concept typically when we hear the word
judge we don't think about it in a
positive way say no Indian parents they
edify great behavior and they judge bad
behavior unfortunately the current
Society in America today we are a little
bit too accepting of every single
behavior and these kids are grown up
saying if Mom's not judging that if
Mom's not edifying that I guess I'm just
going to choose to be the Little Neck
you know little nausea next I'm going to
look up to this guy you know Sam Smith
I'm gonna go look up this guy so I think
we have a hero making machine problem in
America and parents need to paint a
better picture of what a hero is for
their kids
foreign
[Music]